let me get to mannix though well first
of all mannix was
trending last night because he had a
freezing cold tip well this is a great
way to welcome maddox in
chris maddox senior nba writer for
sports illustrated most recent column
there will always be a goat debate
but lebron has made a compelling case
that there shouldn't be
before we get to chris mannix mannix
back september 27th
of last year said the following about
the lakers on this show
yeah i get killed every year talking
about the lakers with you because
i tend to be more skeptical as i was
last season but
is it not more likely that the lakers
missed the playoffs than
than the championship i i think that
wait
this year right now this year you so the
odds are better
that they miss the playoffs than they
win the championship
i would say so yes wow okay all righty
so at the time why did you feel that way
well the lakers despite adding anthony
davis
were a team with myriad questions
whether it was the head coach or a
patchwork roster and look i've been
forced to eat some version of that clip
for the better part of the last couple
of weeks dan
but to those laker fans out there i'd
like to congratulate you
on all the times you tweeted
and talked about and wrote about how
frank vogel was the guy
that he was the man that was gonna lead
you to a championship i would like to
salute you
for believing in dwight howard after all
these years
and all these teams i would like to
applaud you for saying that right
[Music]
john rondo for a disappointing first
year with the lakers and by the way
nearly being replaced in february by
darren collison
people forget a little bit about that
for believing that rajon rondo
would be a difference maker of equalizer
bravo
fans you you are nostra damn damas
predicting all this stuff so you stand
by your comments from september
it was september they weren't
they i i believe it was like the second
week in july dan or the first week in
july
while the lakers were still trying to
wait out kawhi leonard when they had
like unofficially three players on the
roster when it was
anthony davis lebron james and kyle
kuzma you
we both know that winning a championship
is more than just top level talent
now all the laker moves that they made
that rob palinka made
they worked out brilliantly but do not
anyone
sit here and tell me that you were sure
about any of these patchwork decisions
uh in september or even october who
deserves the most credit
for the lakers as champions this year
uh you always got to start with lebron
um
and not just because of the numbers and
the performance on the floor but you
heard
several laker players you heard rob
palinka allude to this
last night that labrador ship
in the bubble was invaluable and i guess
you could even perceive that his
leadership and kind of patching this
team together early on
and making it a cohesive unit was big
and then you get down to the bubble and
all the trying circumstances to have a
leader like lebron james in that mix
i i don't think you could put it you
know i don't think you can calculate
exactly how much that's worth so not
only was he producing
at an extremely high level a
ridiculously high level
for a player his age at this stage of
his career but what he did off the
court was clearly influential with not
to the lakers success
i'm trying to find the negative today
because somebody's going to find the
negative with lebron
and and i was wondering if they were
going to say well
it was an easier road in the bubble
which i don't believe
or lebron after the game saying
i want my damn respect like i'm just
trying to figure out so help me
understand
how us talking heads are going to spin
this a different way
from lebron james in the lakers i i
don't know how you do that
like it's not that's
bronze fault that the clippers fizzled
out in the second round
it's not lebron's fault that the bucks
didn't hold up their end of the bargain
in getting to the finals this isn't
boxing you play who's in front of you
you don't get to choose
who your opponents are and the lakers
did that and you know gentlemen swept
their way through the
western conference finals and you know
needed six games to get rid of miami so
i don't look at the schedule
as as you can't look at that as a
negative you can't uh you know pin that
on
lebron james and look dan i wrote last
night
nothing will ever top what lebron
accomplished in cleveland
i mean that will always be the pinnacle
of his career not just because he
brought a championship to cleveland but
the circumstances in which he did it to
come back from 3-1 down against the you
know
greatest team in nba history at least in
the regular season
that will always be number one this to
me
is number two like this right here what
he did
uh in this season with this group in
this bubble in this harsh environment
and it was a harsh
environment it's not an easy place to go
and win a championship what he did there
this will rank as the second most
significant team accomplishment
in lebron james career anyone that tells
you otherwise uh just has
some kind of bone to pick with lebron
james we're talking to chris mannix
senior nba writer for sports illustrated
his most recent column there will
always be a goat debate but lebron james
has made a compelling case that there
shouldn't be
on james and other final masterpiece
yeah i don't want to get into the
greatest of all time because nobody ever
changes their opinion have you ever been
around somebody where you have a
discussion about this
and they go oh you know what on second
it's like politics people just don't
change their mind people are firmly
entrenched in this
i always just caution people appreciate
what you're seeing
because you will not see this he doesn't
miss playoff games
he wins he's he has hit more clutch
shots than anybody in the playoffs in
history
he doesn't miss games he plays hard he's
averaging a triple double at his age
with what he's done
he's the great longevity wise he's the
greatest player of all time in my
opinion and you know maybe kareem you
can make that argument but
we you know we try to fit him into a
square peg and he's a round hole
you know it's just he's not michael
never be and i i
i just i don't know why i have to defend
him
because but it feels like they're just
people out there who are never going to
let him in that select group
that that fraternity for some reason why
is that well
i mean everyone kind of gets into their
silos right when it comes to this debate
whether it's
jordan lebron a few people on the
outside that might say kareem or wilt or
even bill russell
into that mix you're right you don't
change opinions
in any of these types of debates you can
point out that jordan lost
multiple times in the first round people
don't care they always
point back to lebron's finals record and
say that's proof that he's not
on jordan's level but i'm with you for
for longevity to be
in his 260th nba playoff game
to post his 28th triple double to do it
while being the best player on the floor
in his 17th season his age 35 season
i don't know what you come up with to
dispute that and what i wrote last night
dan was
even if you can say if you want to say
lebron
is not the greatest of all time there's
probably going to come a point
in lebron's career where you can't say
that because lebron
is not close to done i mean the lakers
they're going to enter next season
assuming anthony davis resigns
as a co-favorite at worst to win a
championship
then you go ahead dan to the summer of
2021
and if the lakers keep their books as
tight as they are right now
they're gonna have like 30 million plus
in cap space
to go and recruit either another max
level player
or a bunch of different players to fill
in the holes
around lebron anthony davis so you can
say four championships doesn't equal six
but lebron may not get just get there he
may eclipse that number before his
career is said and done
and the miami heat um i loved watching
them during the regular season
i loved the way they played uh i have
newfound respect for jimmy butler
because i didn't think he was a
superstar
i thought he was a very good player and
he got a bunch of younger players to
listen to him
and the other places the other stops
that's why i think he got frustrated i
think we looked at jimmy butler as the
problem and
you know that's on me uh because i found
out that he wants you to be great and he
demanded a lot and those younger players
god they played hard and
i can't say enough about what riley and
spoelstra did for the miami heat this
year and putting that and keeping it
together
butler and miami were quite literally
the perfect fit
you had an uber competitive player who
held everyone around him to the highest
of standards
joining a team with a coach and a
president
that had the exact same mindset not to
say that jimmy couldn't have
accomplished this
in philadelphia i think one of the great
off-season
gaffes of this century will be that the
76ers
didn't make jimmy butler a black at five
five year max level contract buffer
that will go down probably as one of the
bigger mistakes
that we've seen in recent memory but
this was an ideal fit between player
and team and a roster that was open to
being held as accountable
as butler wanted to hold him to account
to and the heat are going to go into
next year
in a similar position as the lakers
they'll probably bring back goron dragic
on a short-term deal a big money deal
and then they dan
like the lakers are gonna be in a
position in 2021
to dangle that max contract in front of
giannis or whoever else might be out
there on the open market and you can't
tell me dan
that the greatest audition that the
heat could have given for giannis
tentacombo was how they proceeded in
these playoffs
they showed giannis on tv every night in
front of him in that second round
that they were a winning organization
they already had south beach they
already had pat riley and his
championship rings
but they showed giannis that they could
win with this group
they could win they could say imagine
what we can do if you join this team in
a year plus
when's the next season start
at this point i've long believed martin
luther king day was the earliest date
we might even see this bleed into
february
um you know in talking to a few
executives about this late last night
nobody really has any idea like they're
playing it week to week they know that
adam silver
wants to get fans back in the building
and if it means
pushing the season a little bit further
into the fall
uh or the winter rather they silver
might be willing to do that if it means
they can get
x number of games all in buildings all
with fans
i think that is the top priority right
now but i would not expect teams
to be back into training camp before
january and at this point it might be
early to mid february before we see an
nba season start
thanks for all your contributions this
year certainly from inside the bubble
and outside
and uh we'll talk to you soon thank you
chris
bye lakers fans